miles de brasileños salieron a las
calles de río de janeiro sao paulo y
otras 50 ciudades para pedir la
destitución de jair bolsonaro las
caravanas fueron organizadas por
movimientos de izquierda e incluso de
derecha que apoyaron al mandatario a su
llegada al poder en enero de 2019 pero
que más tarde se desvincularon de él por
su gestión de la pandemia de coronavirus
para lo cual el país está viendo que
convulsionaron no podemos tener salud ni
vacunas sólo sacando a bolsonaro del
gobierno podremos pedir cosas básicas
salida pongo cosas mínimas y apoyos que
restar por eso estamos hoy aquí un
movimiento de renovación política en un
frente unido con gente que piensa
diferente exigiendo el juicio político a
jair bolsonaro
bolsonaro según un estudio de la
universidad de sao paulo y la ong
conectas derechos humanos existe una
estrategia promovida por el gobierno de
bolsonaro para propagar el hobbit 19 en
brasil a partir de vetos presidenciales
y una campaña para desacreditar a las
autoridades sanitarias dichas políticas
han hecho que el gobierno de bolsonaro
este reto
en la campaña de vacunación contra el
coi 19 que empezó esta semana pero que
no es suficiente para inocular a los 210
millones de habitantes que tiene brasil
datos del rastreador our world in data
indican que un poco más de 500 mil
personas han recibido la primera dosis
de la vacuna contra el virus es decir el
0,2 por ciento de la población este país
es el tercero en el mundo con más casos
de contagio y el segundo después de eeuu
con las muertes superando los 215 mil
fallecimientos los asistentes
manifestaron también contra el fin de la
ayuda de emergencia con la que 68
millones de brasileños casi un tercio de
la población pudo sobrellevar desde
abril hasta finales de diciembre los
devastadores efectos de la pandemia